it's like words a failing me on this one
[Applause]
[Music]
violence Voyager
I don't know folks have heard about this
thing or not it had a very limited run
in the end us theaters back in July and
it's actually being released onto
digital platforms on the 21st of this
month which does actually mean full
disclosure I got to see this before it
got released digitally so I got slightly
advanced eyes on this like that never
happens so I like that's cool I was not
paid to review this to be clear I was
simply given access to it to review and
also give it an embargo date which is a
first for me as well guy it's almost
like I'm professional
isn't that a terrifying thought okay
speaking of terrifying violence Voyager
this is an animated film originating
from Japan in a very unusual animated
style and it is it is a creepy horror
gross
let's kill children kind of thing and
like I'm not even gonna spoiler that
like you kind of know this going in kids
are not only going to be endangered kids
are gonna die and I I haven't gotten a
ton into Japanese horror but I will say
what a little bit of Japanese horror I
have indulged in Japan seems way more
casual about child murder
then then us horror tends to be and you
know I've said before her that it tends
to identity squeamish about that I
wasn't excessively with this though and
that's gonna tie back to the animation
style and I'll get to that let's start
with the plot because the plot is
actually relatively straightforward you
have two young boys
an American boy named Bobby and his best
friend a [ __ ] and they just they just go
on a little trip and they go up a
mountain and they they come across
something called violence Voyager which
appears to be a slightly rundown bit of
a janky sort of amusement park and know
what the heck they go in and things get
real bad real real bad this the plot and
and honestly the story overall not super
original even in terms of like the
horrific stuff that happens and if
you're wondering we are dealing with
straight-up bloody gore violence we are
dealing with body horror we are dealing
with Mad Science we are dealing with I
don't even know what that is
kind of stuff just all over the place
and it is not excessively unusual if you
were to plot it out on paper at least as
far as horror things that incorporate
one or more of these elements go which
brings us to the animation the visual
presentation of things of this thing
because I have I'm not gonna say I've
never seen something like this because
I've been to enough animation festivals
and seen enough experimental animated
shorts that I think I have seen some of
the exits before but I am J impressed to
see that somebody did this for a
feature-length film and pulled it off
and made it work the best way to
describe the animation style I'm gonna
say animations that are more than an art
style because it's not just artistic
aesthetic were talking about the actual
way in which the thing is animated I
would call it paper puppetry
I don't want I
don't confuse that with like paper
stop-motion or paper crafts kind of
stuff like like that original pilot for
South Park was that's that's not quite
what we're dealing with here so the way
it is is any given shot the pose that
characters are in is static but they may
move around but it's not done with
computer and it's not done like
stop-motion it's done in camera so like
to use an example and to use like a
little paper puppet my daughter made for
me a few years ago if a scene had this
wolf in it it would appear here and it
would move across the screen in that
fashion better than that because it's
not quite as janky as me doing it but
that's the way these things move but
also I really want to impress upon you
that it's unique art it's a unique piece
basically every single shot so like
every new pose it's not like they're
reusing the same you know paper doll a
bad paper puppet sort of thing for every
shot they're completely unique fully
colored you know cut out every single
time and but that is the way that they
move and like individual parts as well
like maybe just the hand moves but again
you can tell the hand is just kind of in
and out it's it's really weird but you
get used to it quicker than you'd think
but and this is kind of vital it never
becomes normal
so like to pull an example with say
something like Spider Man into the
spider purse which has an incredibly
unique animation style as well in terms
of the way that it was melding 2d and 3d
animation elements and that one by the
time it was done I had kind of forgotten
how unique the animation style was not
because like it lost its luster but just
because I become so acclimatization
this never feels normal and that's not a
complaint that's not a criticism that is
an asset to this thing because the story
and the story like I said is weird and
is twisted but to the the animation
keeps you wrong-footed and like in a
mental like this is not right it's it's
like it's not quite uncanny valley
because i'm kennie valley you know is
derived from the premise of it looks
almost real but not quite or it looks
almost human but not quite like this
doesn't look real at all but it's like
it's some kind of version where it's
like uncanny animated Valley and I don't
mean like trying to be for to real
animation but like it's almost like
animation but not quite and it like it
just throws you off the whole way
through in a way that actually
complements the story in complements
what's going on other elements like the
music's pretty good it's not overly
elaborate but it's wonderfully moody the
voice acting is not great i amateurish
is a little harsh but it's not it's not
naturalistic it's not particularly
convincing it's very obvious that the
kids are being voiced by people who
aren't actually kids but again I think
partly because the animation never feels
real and never feels like natural in any
way it didn't bother me that the voice
work was the way that it was I think
under almost any other circumstance the
I would be complaining about the voice
work but here no like from right when it
started I'm like whole thing gonna be
like this okay and it really wasn't
swallowing that really did put me in a
headspace of okay show me what you got
how weird is this gonna get and it gets
pretty weird and like honestly content
warnings up down this thing so like I
said
endangered children dead children body
horror
nudity that is also a very off-putting
like a lot of what's done here you
flat-out could not do in live-action
like no one would let you do this in
live-action which i think is again a
little bit of Japanese horror that I've
taken in so far I think that is a thing
that tends to happen with Japanese
animated horror films they really go for
doing something that no one would ever
let them do in live-action that's kind
of going on here it's a really unique
really creepy really unsettling
shockingly engaging like I didn't detach
from this at any point I'm like ah and I
don't wanna I don't want to get into
spoilers to talk too much more about
specifics what I will say though is if I
had one complaint it's that I wish the
climax was weirder so basically with
about 20 minutes to go basically get it
going into act 3 of the story
I was hoping for one more final you
didn't see this coming bit of insanity
but it it was done it had shown me all
the weirdness it was going to show me
setting up act 3 and then act 3 was
relatively straightforward ish like it's
still using all of the weirdness that
had been introduced in the film up to
that point so that's all there but there
was no new weirdness introduced in the
third act and I kinda wish there was it
made the third act feel not
disappointing and it wasn't
anticlimactic
it's just kind of that it was it almost
felt too normal it felt like this thing
kept catching me off guard with doing
something else really weird and then
just kind of stopped doing weird stuff
for its final act again not like
completely stopped like all the weird
stuff introduced
was all still there but it was done
throwing me new curve balls and I really
gotten into the rhythm of the curve
balls and I mean I suppose you could
argue that stopping throwing curve balls
is its own kind of curveball but that
feels like a bit of a cop-out again it's
not it's not like it falls apart it's
really solid all the way through but it
it's run out of new things to make to
make you go ah by the time it's done
like with about 20 minutes left to go
you've seen everything that's gonna ski
view about this and there's plenty to
make you scheme about this and again the
animation style is so weird and
shouldn't work not for if not for
feature-length like I said I'm pretty
sure I've seen someone do this in a
short before and it's the kind of weird
animation style I would never expect to
be made to work for the length of a
feature story but there it is so yeah
violence Voyager if you are looking for
something weird and unusual both in
terms of the sum of the elements the
story's gonna tell and definitely in
terms of the visual presentation I would
recommend checking it out
now as I said it is going to be
available on digital platforms on the
21st of October this month it's gonna be
on Amazon DirecTV Vimeo flicks fling
Vudu Fandango and AT&T is being released
by dark coast and props to them for
bringing this thing over cuz yeah it's a
weird one it's an oddity and it's the
kind that if you enjoy a usual animation
if you enjoy twisted horror especially
if you enjoy both I'm a little bit more
into weird animation than I am into
twisted horror but I'm game for twisted
horror every now and then and I I was
legitimately impressed with the
animation style
it sounds like cheap-jack the way I had
to describe it but you kind of need to
see it you need to see it in action and
to realize oh okay so props to this
movie and I'm yeah
I would recommend checking it out if you
think it's gonna be up your alley
like I said hard are so know what you're
getting but might just be the right bit
of weirdness for some of you I suspect
that's why it's thoughts on this thing I
can't ask you if you've seen her won't
you think about it cuz it's not out yet
but do you have any animated things
especially in a horror fan with a really
unusual visual presentation that you
want to recommend whatever you've got
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it you can support me
on patreon it helped me keep the lights
on and keep this thing going
plus there's a bunch of other links down
there below there's the subscribe and
the and the like and social media links
all this stuff click on it or don't I'm
not gonna tell you what to do because at
the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]